um I have an excerpt here from Carl
Sagan's pale blue dot the book okay
which is probably among the most quoted
sentences of the entire book if you
allow me
okay okay thank you our posturings our
imagined self-importance the delusion
that we have some privileged position in
the universe are challenged by this
point of pale light
our planet is a lonely Speck in the
great enveloping Cosmic dark
in our obscurity in all this vastness
there is no hint that help will come
from elsewhere to save us from ourselves
and it goes on and on and on but that
and that's just representatively
beautiful
of a very long passage and it's a take
on that pale blue dot so Carolyn you
wanted to reprise this so what happened
there yes
Valentine's Day 1990 November 13th 1990
I get a phone call from NASA
headquarters telling me out of the
Imaging team leader I'm sure those
people who didn't want to pay overtime
were like damn
well anyway so uh and my first team
meeting my first team meeting was I
think early December of 1990 and that's
what I told my you know I didn't tell
them we wanted we're going to do the
pale blue dot but that's where I set my
goals for the team but anyway so
fast forward a number of years again to
20 uh I don't know what it was 2010-11
and I'm starting to think where can I
find the time or the in the in the uh
the plans for all the imagery we were
going to do uh where can I slot in
another pale blue dot and in doing that
trying to think of where we were going
to put it it occurred to me how great it
would be if we just do the pale blue dot
with a Twist and that twist was going to
be that I thought will invite people the
world over
to participate in this we'll tell them
ahead of time not after the image is
taken like everybody else had done up
until that point we'll tell them ahead
of time at this certain time
and date
we're going to take a picture of you
here on the earth that the window the
picture ticking window lasts 15 minutes
we want you all to go out you know
straighten up comb your hair go out you
know and look up
you know at the sky even if you're on
the other side of the earth I saw Chuck
in that photo he had like
he had spinach in his teeth and clearly
I was not wearing pants
[Laughter]
anyway like they wasn't so clear Chuck
don't worry
[Laughter]
okay so I remember I remember Carolyn
because there were news or ALS about
this to get everybody to participate
people did participate and we said you
know just go out
look up at the sky think of all of us
here on this planet all in Earth's
creatures on one planet think of our
isolation and the Blackness of space and
think of how precious life is and our
own lives are on this planet and just
smile at being alive on a pale blue dot
what's up star top fans you know a lot
of you have reached out to me and asked
what am I doing a comedy special well
guess what it's happening that's right
this fall I'm taping my first science
comedy special here in Manhattan so if
you're going to be in the area I want
you to be there because I need the most
science literate audience that I can
have and that means you so go to Chuck
Nice comment.com and use code StarTalk
for your exclusive chance to make a
pre-sale purchase for the tickets it's a
very limited supply of tickets so you
want to do it as early as possible and
that means now Chuck nicecomic.com use
code start talk and we'll see you this
fall with the rest of the StarTalk game
Carolyn Porco Madame Saturn I got a
question for you
I'm told July 19th
is the 10th anniversary of what it's the
10th anniversary of probably the most
beautiful image of Earth ever taken and
it's called the deviated smile uh and we
took Earth's picture
from uh basically from a solar eclipse
at Saturn Saturn was eclipsing the Sun
so we got the chance to look close to
the Sun at the Earth without the Sun
impairing the picture getting scattered
light and so on and it was special
because we uh like no other Earth
picture before we had invited
the uh the people of the world to
participate told them to go out while
the picture's being taken look up think
about your position on this beautiful
pale blue dot and think about how
precious your life is how how unique
your planet is for for being the host of
life in our solar system and just smile
at the sheer thought of being alive
and that's what happened
take that as a selfie Kim Kardashian
no no well if was Earth twerking that
would that would boost the social social
media value if Earth was twerking during
that selfie there could have been a lot
of people twerking we wouldn't have
known it so you were ahead of the
Imaging team of Cassini that took the
photo did this require some convincing
of NASA to get them to agree because the
original pale blue dot uh from back in
Voyager I knew had some resistance
because of the cost and it wasn't in the
original plan and there's no obvious
science to come of it but it certainly
has cultural value and I think it's high
time NASA recognizes its role on the
cultural landscape not just the
scientific one
permission for this and I you know I
didn't do it
not only just coming out now Carolyn you
know you know there were those famous
for which it's uh you know it's better
to beg forgiveness than as permission
right but and actually eventually this
happened late in the mission we got into
orbit around Saturn in 2004 this picture
was taken 2013. so that was nine years
after the start of the mission people
had sort of relaxed about these things
and and more than that then you snuck it
in when they they were relaxed not
looking that's when no one no one knew I
was going to do it but I what I did was
I took I I piggybacked on someone else's
observation there was going to be a
mosaic of the entire
uh sand system with the out to the Rings
anyway that another instrument was going
to do and I just called up the guy and
said look you know I really would where
all the food the footprints that you're
going to put across Saturn in its rings
please dwell a little longer and let us
do RGB red green blue filters uh and
then also when you get down near the
Earth we'd like to take some extra
pictures uh please do that and so it it
happened just it really was a slight
change on a design that already had been
um you know had been proposed uh and and
being cleverly optimistic I mean I you
were being cleverly operated
opportunistic yes yes well I knew you
know I'd been on I've been at work on
this Mission by that time since 1990
that was a long time I knew how to do
this well congratulations on that yeah
uh how are you going to celebrate the
anniversary
like
might uh go album like wave at the sky
or something I don't know
I don't know we have people you know we
had people call into her right on the
website that we set up to collect
responses and there were so many lovely
responses from people well I remember a
man saying that he and his daughter 10
years old they went out you know during
the the event and they had the guys
centered and yeah I raised a glass of
wine and she be her name raised a glass
of Fizzy Pop and we laughed and danced
and who did and hollered and all you
know had a great time so that's a good
way to celebrate and now she's 20.
that's right
yeah yeah so no really it's it's uh I
was so glad I got the opportunity to do
that it was um something I had long
wanted to do I wanted to do it from the
very beginning of being selected as the
Imaging team leader and I got to the
Cassini Imaging team leader and I got to
do it now remind me you started Life as
a rock jock isn't that right no I
started Life as a Rings person a
planetary Rings person oh you are so
your planets all along you didn't come
in as a geologist oh so wait a minute
Rock jock was geologist and not like a
morning DJ okay
cause I was confused so Carolyn wait so
I I thought you had some more overlap
with the with the geology folks well I I
went to uh I was in the division of
geological and planetary Sciences at
Caltech so I got this okay I learned
geology I learned geophysics I learned
all that stuff but your first love is
the universe yes my first love is the
universe and I would encourage like you
you tell people to go out and look up I
would say if you want to have an
overview effect you don't need to go up
in a Jeff faceo spacecraft you just go
out on a dark night with no moan look up
and look at the Milky Way and if you
stare at it long enough and you kind of
force yourself into this frame of mind
you can convince yourself you are
looking at a disc a gigantic disc of
stars your home Galaxy and you will know
like then you're on a spaceship
flying flu and gazing upon this uh this
incredible site which is your home
that's the overview effect
so that's what all these wonderful
pictures of the earth taken from afar do
and you can have it whenever you want
from you're saying save your money for
this yeah on the Bezos flight don't
spend your money don't fall asleep it
takes for free you can have it for free
have it for free and if you get a
telescope and you look up you might
actually see Elon musk's Tesla while
you're not spending the money tomorrow
yeah I wish he was in it
no the aliens because there is a he does
have a mannequin in it I'm just trying
to imagine aliens coming upon Earth and
they first see a Tesla right with like a
mannequin but they don't know it's a
mannequin maybe they think that's like a
petrified human right I gotta tell you
these humans are pretty damn stiff
too
who wants to go there oh yeah that's not
a party place next year after the year
it's like just
um falls apart we may all we may all end
up plastic
yeah
all right well Carol congratulations on
this anniversary this well-deserved
10-year anniversary for your hard work
uh dating back and those interested we
have an entire Star Talk episode just
featuring Carolyn porco's expertise so
anyway again thank you Carolyn for
joining us Chuck thank you man always a
pleasure all right Neil deGrasse Tyson
here keep looking up
foreign
[Music]